so today we're gonna be talking about
post-modern css
um if you're not a child of the 80s like
i am you might not have experienced
a lot of these things i got a chance to
live through a lot of this uh
and really struggle with my uh with my
computers in the early days so
i like to define it much like i would
define historical eras right so
we had a set of pre-history the 70s and
the 80s
it was all about bulletin boards and
point-to-point connections you literally
dialed into somebody else's network and
all that good stuff
uh the internet as a thing was much more
based around research
sharing documents and really again just
kind of accessing those simple networks
but then we found some enlightenment
right we moved into the classical era
sir tim berners-lee
not at the time a knight of the british
realm at that point
uh invented http the html language
and the first browser the world wide web
web browser right the very first web
browser was literally named the world
wide web
and so we come into this era we're able
to share things we're able to access it
not just researchers are using it it's
really good stuff overall
right but then like all society like all
civilization we do usually enter a dark
time the middle ages
uh the dark ages as we might refer to
them in the uh in the actual classical
sense
um i like to refer to this you know how
you got like the the rise in the fall of
the roman empire we also have kind of
the rise and fall of css and we're going
to go deeper into that in a minute
but i'm going to gloss over it for now
we're going to move on to the modern era
things become much much
more easy much easier to use in the
modern era
right we have html5 we have css3 we have
advanced javascript all sorts of great
frameworks
we have bootstrap we have foundation we
have these things that make our lives
very very easy
kind of across the board right but we
also
see some things that we might not like
and we'll dive into that as well
but in post-modernity right coming out
of that that modern era
i like to think that our future is all
about super advanced layouts
re-emergence of unique designs not
necessarily even like great user
experience although there's plenty of
room for that as well but like
punk rock like that was a big
post-modern kind of thing
so let's actually talk about our post
modernity again here's that quote from
sujuko
it is about a reaction to objectivity
it's about
seeking subjectivity
so what is our objectivism on the web
especially around css
so this to me is our
objectivism every website looking almost
exactly the same this is actually
like the only bootstrap page is the name
of this of this little site
and it's a very familiar look and feel
lots of websites look like this i'm not
going to knock it because it is a very
useful
design it is very easy for users to use
and it doesn't take us a lot of work to
put together
but every website in the world looks
like this so this is kind of our
objective truth
around what the web is supposed to be
right
not necessarily what it could be not
necessarily what it should be
so again going back to the post-modern
definitions um
what is our meta narrative right we have
a meta-narrative especially around css
and it is that
css sucks um says every developer ever
as uh as referenced by this awesome gif
of peter griffin
griffith trying to uh close some blinds
and i love it and usually this would be
the point that the audience would laugh
and everyone kind of have a good chuckle
so go ahead and give me some
some laws for some raffles in the chat
and uh and we'll go from there
we'll pretend like i heard you uh so
yeah so let's actually dig into
why most developers think
css sucks because it doesn't and it's
awesome and i'm gonna prove it today
so the rise and fall css our middle ages
are dark ages and really what it boils
down to is there's a battle over
style sheets browsers implementation all
that thank you for the walls and chat i
appreciate it
so why did we get here and and where can
we go
so css started really really strong
actually so in the mid 90s mid to early
90s
people were thinking all right html is
not quite enough it is a very semantic
way of structuring a document but
doesn't really take into account
the more marketing-y things that we want
to do on the web more people were
adopted into web
we saw a whole bunch of stuff happening
in terms of like simple layout in html
so people were like all right we need to
be able to style this stuff not in html
let's separate our authoring languages
out
so i'm going to again kill these names
but pecan william lee
and bert boss started working together
on the css one specification they were
actually competing specs at the time
uh for how you would handle styles and
the reason that css won as a
specification was actually because there
was a belief
that users were going to add a style
sheet to their own browser and they
wanted to make sure that that
last style sheet could override
a site's styles and so that's why we
have the cascade we want that cascade we
want the user to be able to implement
things
to override ourselves that's why browser
extensions work that's why this is still
an important thing
the cascade is still super important
today but 1994 they start working on the
spec
96 the css1 specification is complete
and by that point ie3 kind of adopts it
and by
2000 99 that specification
was in ie5 which was probably the most
prominent web browser of the time
um so yeah about six years from start to
finish and it all kind of was
implemented with very few bugs nothing
to worry about
so we start out strong the middle part
not so much right so 98
they have all these new ideas they want
to implement and so they start working
on the css 2 specification the level 2
specification
and actually enters its first working
draft in 98
and then in 2000 so just two years later
just like that css1 spec
it becomes a recommendation and so it's
like all right browsers you can start
implementing this this is good to go
but then between 2000 and 2007 it
literally went back and forth between
recommendation and working draft like
five times
uh and that's not great if you want
browsers to support
the actual real specification and that's
why we have
so many bugs in like older browsers
around
these implementations why floats don't
work exactly the same way why
widths and paddings and the box model is
kind of different between
ie6 and ie7 and firefox or i guess it
was
still mozilla at the time but that's why
we had these weird things because the
specification
didn't reach maturity until 2007 and in
fact it reached maturity not as css 2
the css 2 level 1 or css2 revision 1. so
css 2.1
so all that back and forth really
muddied the waters around how browsers
were implementing it and finally by 2011
we had it fully published so it's really
was that 13 years
of back and forth and figuring the
specification out
and what we got was kind of a like i
said a mired
mess of of what the browsers implemented
so
the future and why css3 is better than
css 2 or 2.1
or even css1 at that point is because
we've gone to this module
system so now when we talk about css3
we're not going to talk about css4
we're going to talk about different
modules gaining traction going through
working draft and into recommendation on
their own
so the browsers can implement smaller
pieces so you can see here we've got
like
selectors level three and four for all
the new cool selectors we get
grid layout multi-column layout flex is
in here too
image stuff all these things can go on
their own process and the browsers can
implement little pieces
so it's a really cool philosophy that
they've adopted and it's going to make
things
hopefully less buggy going forward i
think you can even see how that works
with the fact that when grid launched
uh three or four years ago into into the
first browsers
there were very few bugs there were bugs
but way fewer than what we would get
from like floats and box sizing
so if you're curious there are a couple
other things you can read about like
this whole evolution of css and the saga
do google search on these the css saga
the evolution of css they're really cool
uh historical artifacts for how all of
this worked
so that's not really why you're here you
don't really care about the history
probably i care about the history
because again
i think about things very oddly but you
might get into the new hotness right why
is css awesome
what are we going to do today so my goal
for you is i want you to today or
tonight or
tomorrow after you've kind of gotten
over all the new stuff you learned today
adopt
at least one of these properties and
shoot me a tweet or something about it
and let me know
what you decided to adopt but we're
going to go back and forth between some
graphical things and some layout things
and so i want to start kind of easy so
we're going to talk about css gradients
so back in the day to do gradients we'd
have to do like image crops and slices
and then background repeating and stuff
like that
why use images when css can do amazing
things out of the box
so very important always think about how
many browsers support it the cool thing
about gradients is that they're
supported
across the board the the kind of light
green is there because there's
some multiplication errors that you get
from safari
uh around some i think they call it uh
pre-multiplied colors in the transparent
keywords so there's like a bug
but it is fully supported it's about 98
support worldwide
for the css gradients so let's do some
gradients for fun and profit here's the
simplest implementation
we've got we've got gradating from a
light red to a dark red
and it is in syntax a background
image it is not a background color it's
not a background it's a background image
and that's because the browser is
actually going to be rendering
an image behind the scenes for you so it
is actually an image and it feels weird
when you first write that the first time
but
you get used to it and you and you know
that it's actually an image back there
so yeah it takes a function css as a
value it is a linear gradient for linear
gradient linear dash gradient
and then it takes some number of of
arguments so in this case it has
the starting point for our gradient and
the ending point so light red to dark
red
but you can also control the direction
at which it goes
and you can use a whole bunch of
different values for that first argument
in this case i'm using the degree unit
in css specifically meant for
angling of items uh you could use turns
you could use um
there there's no you and then there's
some keywords we'll get into in a second
so you can
direct the way that your gradient
is going you can also control how many
stops you get so you can see here
instead of a degree we're now getting
some keywords to
bottom to actually direct our um our
gradient from the top of the browser to
the bottom of it
and then we get a starting point we get
the next stop where it says we want to
be fully at
the dark red color by the 50 mark and
this goes for any
length unit in css so percentages rams
ams pixels
anything you want there it will render
out and it's basically where the next
color
should be fully implemented by that
point and then you can add as many color
stops as you want along the way
and so in this point we say we want to
go back to that original
red by the 70 mark and that gives us
this kind of like dark
gradient stripe in the middle which can
be super handy for making things legible
in various ways
if you don't like lines you can also do
a radial gradient which can give a nice
feel of depth to your page
and so the syntax is very very similar
so it takes a it's another function
radial dash gradient
takes some parentheses and then takes
those same two colors the starting point
and the ending point
in this case the starting point is going
to be in the middle of
our radius right so in the middle of the
page and then the ending point goes out
from there
you can also do a few different things
with what kind of radial it is
in this case it's a circle you can
control where it's positioned where that
center point the circle is positioned so
in this case
it's up there at the top left corner
with that ten percent zero
declaration and again just like we did
before you can also give it a length
unit of some sort
to actually see where that dark red
color gets in
you can also do some intense stuff with
repeats and it doesn't have to be a
gradient as it turns out
so here's something again you might need
to shield your eyes because it might be
a little harsh for you but
we have stripes and this that can
actually be like very very powerful in
terms of like maybe not quite this harsh
but like using this as backgrounds can
add a lot of texture to your page
so in this case we're doing a lot of
stuff i'm going to break it out piece by
piece but what we're doing is we're
calling the repeating linear gradient
function we're telling you what
direction to go in right to top right
and then we're providing the stops along
the way and let's break that out real
fast
so again first we get direction and then
we take that first color
which is our light red and then we're
going to do the first color again
at 20 pixels out and that's going to
give us a hard edge on the left and
right hand side of it instead of
actually having it go as a gradient
it's no longer gradients between the two
is now a hard edge
and then at that same point at that 20
pixel point we introduce our second
color
again so we don't get any sort of fade
we get a hard line there
and then to fight the fade on the other
side we then double that so we say all
right at the 40 pixel
mark i want you to still be that same
color
and because this will repeat it goes
back to the first color directly after
that
so again you get that hard line in there
so gradient stripes are awesome
they are apparently spats spirit animals
so yeah i love
i love the syntax and it's a good like
way it's good appetizer into what we're
doing here today
but you're probably interested more in
layout and i can i can completely
understand that because
part of what people think css sucks at
is doing layout
and layout has been hard and that's why
we've got as many frameworks as we do
so flexbox gives us truly responsive
flexible unidirectional layout and it is
completely and utterly supported in all
browsers we tend to care about
if you need to use it pre ie 10 don't
use it because
ie10 is first where we get it ie 1011
has some some decent-sized bugs in there
as well as some older version of safari
i'm not going to talk about those today
but there's a website you can look up
called flexbugs it lists out all the
different
browser implementation issues across the
board
let's talk about syntax so here we have
some tomato which is my personal
favorite css color on light blue
so we've got six boxes this is the way
the browser typically renders right
we've got
block level they stack down the page
they are 100 of their container
we're going to set up some simple styles
we've got a 510 pixel wide box
we've got some margins to do some
centering light blue background
and again a little bit of extra stuff on
our boxes
but then to get them to go side by side
previously so before flexbox we would
use floats
so all i've done is add float left to
the code
and this is what we get and everything
side by side and that sounds great
but what happened to our light blue well
because floats are intended to have
text wrap around things our heights
collapse when you use floats and so the
parent element the container doesn't
know how tall it should be and so it has
a height of zero
so we implemented a whole bunch of like
different hacks to make this work this
is the clear fix hack you can use an
after element
set content on it display block and then
you clear left and right and that makes
it so that there's an extra element in
there
that identifies where the float stops
and then makes the browser actually
render our blue background
then we have to do a whole bunch of math
right our box size math we've got a
container that's 510 pixels wide
we need to divide that by the six boxes
we've got so we get a box width of 85
pixels
so that should get us all six boxes side
by side right
as it turns out no not so much because
of the way box sizing works
in css by default it is an additive
process
of that padding so we're actually adding
40 pixels left and right to that width
value
and it's no longer what we actually
expect it to be
so we have to do more math gosh darn it
and we have to say all right our
container size is 510 divided by six
and then minus 40 pixels on each of
those to get the actual box width we
need
so we can do that and that gets us our
six boxes side by side
we can do that either with that width
calculation or we can say with 85 pixels
and use a new property which i'm not
going to dive into called box sizing
to tell we actually want that to be a
subtractive element the padding to be
subtracted on it
and that allows us to have a max width
basically set on those elements of 85
pixels
so you can go either way um the math is
kind of the old school way of doing it
box housing border box is obviously a
little bit better
this is why we use frameworks this is a
terrible thing to have to work through
and floats were never intended to do the
complex things we do
this is why flex was created same
example right six boxes in a container
we want to get them side by side so on
our container we change its display
value from the default which is block
to display flex and by default we get
all six boxes side by side
sized by their content right they are
sized by the amount of space those
numbers take up and the padding
so this works out great we don't have to
worry about the math anymore
it is handled for us by flex and then if
we want them to stretch to fill that
space we say flex one and that's going
to allow it to grow it's actually a
shorthand for flex grow flex shrink and
flex
i lost the third it's it's the
percentage that it kind of starts at the
flex
something rather uh i don't really go
that far into it because i believe that
grid
is more important than a lot of that
stuff but we have these six boxes side
by side we don't have to do any math
super handy for us and the great thing
is if our markup changes
our layout changes by default right
those elements stretch
to fit the space available to them the
white space available to them so we get
rid of those three
last three boxes and we get three side
by side instead of having them be like
50
of the box we can also go in and we can
add additional boxes and as long as
there's space for the content of them
there'll be space for them in our flow
so we get seven boxes instead of six
there's a whole bunch of stuff that you
can do including like wrapping things
and stuff like that in flex
uh definitely worth looking into let's
talk about flex layouts and that flex
grow property or that flex property
so if we wanted to do two third one
third layout which is a pretty typical
flow in
in terms of layout on the web we can do
that with the
flex values and we can say flex two for
the box on the left to make it
two-thirds
and we can do flex one on the right-hand
side and what this does is it sets up a
ratio
of the different flex units that you've
got right that ratio is going to be
uh it's going to add all this together
so we have three units which are
unitless units which is fun
and it's going to say that two-thirds
one needs to be two out of three units
and the one-third one is going to be one
out of three units and it gets us
two-thirds one-third
we can also use width plus the box
alignment module which has justified
content
and align items um and we can set widths
on these we can say like the left-hand
side 65
the right-hand side is 33 and then we
can say on the parent
justify my content to put the additional
white space that my boxes don't take up
in between and so as we stretch that
white space in between them
grows it's super handy the justified
content property has a whole bunch of
things you can do with it
from space around space between evenly
centered flex start reflects n they look
like this
uh if you if you don't add the the flex
one value you can actually have them
spaced out in this way
um so yeah it's super super handy you
can also do a lot of things with height
which would have been just the worst
thing to do
in the float era right so very similar
code
uh but we actually increase our height
of our container
right i'm saying 60 bhp 60 of the
browser's height
and you can see by default our two-third
and our one-third items
stretch to fill that space so super
handy
and just like in just like contents we
have a whole bunch of different values
we can use
i don't expect you to remember all these
things somebody mentioned actually in
chat
there's a great css tricks guide to
flexbox and it's amazing i actually have
it as a link in the slides as well
but it does all these things you can
actually align things to the
end of your item which is super handy i
love that that is so hard to do before
flex
so super super important we also do some
directional changes
by default flex things go in a row we
can also reverse them by doing
row reverse and we can also change them
to be in a column instead
and still gain all of our cool box
alignment module properties by using it
so column and column reverse so boxes
one through six
then reverse the boxes six through one
important thing to note this doesn't
change your markup
it doesn't change the source order so
screen readers will still read
from one to six in this case
we can change it to column and we're
going to get a column of our things here
and then we can use justify
content to change the way that it works
uh vertically and horizontally at that
point
so a lot of cool things you can do with
it uh those are my main use cases just
because grid has taken over a lot of the
things i used used to use flex for
but you can definitely check out more
stuff flexbox by animated gif is a great
resource that shows all those box limit
properties and shows them moving around
flexbox froggy and flexbox zombies are
great gamified experiences for learning
all the properties
and then as mentioned in chat css tricks
complete guide to flexbox
is amazing so i sped through that
because i only have a limited amount of
time
let's let's cleanse our palette a little
bit let's go back to the graphical side
and ask the question can browsers
replace
photoshop as it turns out we kind of
they kind of can they've got background
blend mode there's also something called
mix blend mode which allows you to do it
not on backgrounds
but that's something to research on your
own so support for it it's very very
well supported uh 94
globally is a great amount of support uh
ie 11 and the older non-chromium based
edges
don't support this so support it but
with an eye towards readability so if it
fails you still
want the user to be able to read
whatever text you might have around it
um so let's take some kittens because
we're in a palette cleanse mode in
between our layout sections
we have a grid of kittens right they've
just got a little bit of css to make
them a grid they've got a background
size cover to stretch the kitten
to the entire box a place kitten goes in
there and then there's also
already a background color of purple on
it but until we add a background blend
mode only one background can take effect
at that point so background blend mode
takes a whole bunch of things
i publish different values a lot of
which you would see if you were to like
do
a background and select or an opacity
and select inside of photoshop
a lot of those are in here i am not a
math expert but basically what these do
is these change the way the pixels
interact with each other foreground to
background
there's a whole bunch of different cool
stuff you can do i highly recommend like
reading about these things in like
wikipedia
they're super complex though and i'm not
great at math so here's those kittens
again
and here they are with a background
blend mode attached to them
are some super cool kittens now color
dodge uh screen
overlay multiply uh we had to use we
used to have to train our designers not
to use these keywords in photoshop
and now we can use them and it actually
ends up being pretty cool
we can change the background color right
so instead of purple we now get orange
kittens
green kittens great kittens this is
actually a great use case
for darkening a background image and
putting text on top of it again as long
as you keep an eye towards readability
you can also blend between images right
so if i have multiple background images
which are usually separated in that
background image declaration by commas
including gradients so you can do a
gradient in this as well
you can overlay two kittens on top of
each other and create the stuff of
nightmares
or two kittens and a color
so you can actually layer all these
things together and make some really
usually cool sometimes horrifying things
palette cleanser right these are these
are uh
stuff and nightmares let's go off slides
i think everyone's freaking out about
those kittens
uh so grid layout grid is my true love
in terms of
web design nowadays i've been advocating
for it since before it was in the
browsers i actually implemented it on my
blog
before it was actually officially
supported in browsers
and i highly recommend that you go check
it out today because it's actually
really well supported
the browsers in the in the span of like
six months
all implemented grid level one which is
unheard of in terms of like getting
browsers to be on the same page about
something
uh so you can see at the top right the
global support for grid
is 93.77 and i'm going to ignore
the 1.5 percent that's in the light
green and that is internet explorer 11
and 10
and it's using an old version of the
grid specification that doesn't really
dive
with with the uh the modern version and
the reason that the grid even exists
is because of microsoft and internet
explorer so for those of you who dog on
internet explorer maybe don't because
they implemented grid first
they actually wanted to use it for their
metro design they want those squares
to be prominent on their web presence as
well as in the windows 8 experience
so they had to have something uh
grid also introduces a new terminology
because we're actually it's the first
time we've had a first-class
layout engine in the web and so we have
to think about
grid lines grid cells tracks and areas
and so a line is literally just
a vertical or a horizontal axis in terms
of where we place our columns in our
rows
a grid cell is the intersection between
four adjacent grid lines the grid track
is the parallel space between
two adjacent grid lines which could be a
row or a column and then the grid area
is the space inside of four non-adjacent
intersecting grid lines this is directly
from the complete guide to
grid on css tricks so definitely check
that out it is just as comprehensive as
the flex and if you're looking for
uh syntax it is one of the best places
to go
so we're gonna take something very
similar to what we saw before we have a
stack of tomato boxes on light blue
background one is slightly larger than
the others
and then we're going to make this in to
a three column grid
and we're going to use some new syntax
so we've got our container it's always
on the parent that we're doing these
things
we change its context display grid
instead of display block
this is the same thing we did on the
flex examples and then we actually build
out
our columns and our rows so in this case
we want three columns one fr
each the fr unit is a css grid specific
unit
it's the fractional space unit and it
divvies up the available white space in
our layout
amongst the items that have these values
and again you can have this be
like 1fr 2fr 1fr 1fr2fr you can do the
same things you do with like the
flexgrow values
but you can do them in grid as well
and then you can also define out what
sizes you want your rows to be
these can also be any uh any units you
want so you can mix and match pixels
fr units vw units you could even do
percentages even though i would highly
recommend not doing percentages because
the fr unit is way more powerful than a
percentage ever will be
so in our case we're going to say
display grid
we're going to use three 1fr
declarations and that gives us three
fluidly responsive f uh
columns in this area and then we can use
the grid gap
property to allow there to be spacing in
between
our rows and our columns you can specify
specific ones around
rows versus columns or you can have them
be the same unit
now really really exciting in grid gap
grid gap uh
is specifically for grid but there's a
new
non-grid version coming so there's just
the gap property
which will be useful in grid but it's
also coming to flexbox
it's already in firefox i think and it's
in chrome canary right now it's in the
the beta versions of chrome
so that's coming it's gonna make flex
super powerful as well we'll never have
to think about margins again in terms of
doing these layouts
super handy to have so one thing that
gets me excited about
grid is the idea of asymmetry in
our layouts so here we have what looks
to be a very very
simple layout and if we were to do this
in flex or in floats we could very
easily do it
but we'd have like 13 lines of html to
do it and then on top of that it's like
three nested layers
and if you were to do this and say
bootstrap or foundation you probably
even have like four or five or six
nested layers to accomplish all this
right we've got a left-hand column which
is going to take up that full height
we've got a right-hand column
there's a columns div inside of that
right hand column just kind of a lot of
markup for
really just doing our layout it's even
more css it's about 31 lines of css to
accomplish it
there's like three declarations of
display flex there's like
just like contents everywhere there's
some calcs for our widths there's some
weird margin stuff going on there's a
lot of stuff
that is really a pain in the butt so we
don't want to do that we want to move
into a grid solution and to do that
we need to rethink the way we think
about layout on the web
instead of having our layout size by our
content we can now have our content or
we now have our layout size the content
so the content in flex the content and
floats
sizes are layouts in grid we specify
a layout and then our content flows into
that
and the cool thing about it is instead
of thinking in terms of containers which
we do in that content sizing model
we can have our markup be incredibly
clean our promos div
is now just one div no sections nothing
else inside of it
and then four promo spots now the promo
spots could be divs if you want them to
be they could have
more markup inside of them for actual
content but in this case we're just
gonna have four
anchor tags as well and then we're going
to lay it out specifically
on a grid so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to say all right
display grid change it to a grid context
and then set up our columns so if you're
coming from a bootstrap or a foundation
you're in a 12 column methodology so
you'd probably think like the left-hand
side will be six the right-hand side
will be six
all that sort of thing if you're kind of
transitioning away from that you'll
think all right i need four columns
left-hand side
right hand side is two columns in grid
we bake our asymmetry directly into our
column declaration so here
this layout is actually a three column
grid
left hand side is one right hand side is
two more
right so two fr one fr one 1fr meaning
the left-hand side is twice as big as
the right as the two right-hand columns
and then there's this two new properties
right beneath that that i haven't talked
about yet
grid template areas allows us to name
areas and actually stretch areas across
multiple rows and columns
and then we can call that out and place
the elements by name
inside of that so here we've got grid
template areas it takes a set of
quotation marks and those quotation
marks equal
rows right so every set of quotation
marks is going to be a new row
in our layout and then we identify the
cells
inside of it so this is a three column
grid so there are three cells in the top
row
the first one we're going to call main
and then the next two are called second
so let's tell in the browser those two
columns are both
one area and then we have a second row
in those quotation marks
and then we call that main name again
and that's going to tell the browser to
stretch
our main column our main area down two
rows
so this is super awesome this is like
horizontal and vertical two-dimensional
layout at once
and then we toss a third and a fourth
keyword over in those two right hand
bottom columns
and then we set a grid auto rows because
grid automatically will add new rows
as your content grows we don't have to
actually define out the template for our
rows but we do want to give it kind of
some guidance around what it should do
when it creates a new row
so i told it have a min max value a
minimum and a maximum size
the minimum size should be about 20 vh
so about 20 of the browser's height just
give us some good space to work with
and then the maximum size should be one
fr and that will allow our two rows or
three rows or four rows
to grow at the same rate and then we
provide grid gap to make sure that we
have that equal spacing inside
and not have to worry about margins and
clearing margins and all that nonsense
so on the right hand side of this code
we also have our placement css because
grid
is automatically going to try to place
things in one cell
so we have to tell it where to go so the
first child we're going to say go into
grid area main
and that's going to automatically place
it along two rows in that first column
nth child two gets second which is
automatically going to place it in the
two
side columns side in the first row and
then third and fourth will go into the
third and fourth rows
so in general third and fourth here are
actually unnecessary because grid will
automatically flow content into the
third and fourth area
uh but for me i like to be explicit so
that six months down the road i remember
what i'm looking at
but if you're all about line lengths
what this gives us is basically
fifty percent of the markup fifty
percent of the css all to do that
asymmetric
that asymmetric uh promo area
uh much more easily right so it's super
uh so inch i see is it like anonymous
variables but not
yes the non-technical answer would be
yes you're basically creating new
uh keywords that you can then use
wherever you need to inside of this
area so there's a whole lot more out
there in terms of css grid i've kind of
scratched the surface this is like an
overview right
so uh we've got rachel andrew and jen
simmons both represented here they are
some of the
key people that wrote the spec and
there's some of the early
educators around it rachel andrews has a
site called grid by example
super handy to see how all the
properties play together
jen simmons has a youtube channel called
layout land all about css layout in
general
css grid.io is actually west boss's
course on css grid it is free because
mozilla
i think backed up a you know bank truck
to him to get him to make it free
uh you got my course which is actually
practicalcssgrid.com it's two hours long
and you can find out all you need about
grid there the css tricks complete guide
to grid as well as
jen simmons has a website uh a subdomain
website lab.jennsimmons.com and it's a
whole bunch of her like meditations
on weird layout on the web all things
are super awesome
there so i'm a our palette one more time
before i take questions i want to make
sure there's plenty of time for
questions as well
we're going to talk about css shapes
because i i kind of was rough on floats
before floats still serve
a very important purpose on the web if
you have an image and you want to wrap
text around it
floats are the only things that are
going to do that for you so they're not
evil they just only have one use case
and now we can only use them for one use
case because we have flex and because we
have
a grid so let's make those floating
images
interesting again with css shapes very
important to note again just like in our
blend modes not supported in ie
or the old versions of edge only
supported in chromium edge
as well as full support in firefox
chrome safari so super awesome we can
use it in all those
uh there so let's take a simple example
we have a circle in our image
right and then it has this hard edge
around it right we float it left and the
text wraps around it and that's great
but it's a square
in terms of that hard edge so before we
say all right this is good enough call
the day
but now we can use a property called
shape outside and we can actually
specify a few different things we can do
with it
so very easily we can have our text
actually flow around in a circular shape
around our circle so we have all that
same stuff then we just add shape
outside circle
and we get it super awesome super easy
we can also do polygons
so you can have this kind of wiggly edge
on the left hand side which is super fun
the code looks at them like this uh we
set a width and a height on it so that
it can actually be defined there
and then we shape outside polygon i
would never write this polygon code by
hand
if you look up clip path or css shapes
clippy you can see the links right there
bennettfilly.com
clippy this is actually a really great
tool for actually designing out your
polygons
both for clip path and for css shapes so
you can do some really cool stuff in
there
you can also have your own smiling face
and upper torso
represented and have the text wrap
around that by using the shape outside
url and the url is going to go to an
image
that is a transparent mask of what you
want the text to wrap around
so in this case it is a black version of
my entire silhouette here and then i
provide a shape
margin to allow it to kind of bump out
from my body just a little bit there
so super cool you get my smiling face
text wrapping around it cool for like
doing some editorial workflows and doing
some like
cool new things on your sites you can
also
have it kind of squish in like this
there's there's a specification coming
the shape
inside but i don't think it's anywhere
close to recommendation yet
so you can use shape outside to put this
together and you can have two items
a left and a right one be polygons and
squish the text in like this
so you can have some really cool looking
things
css all without too much worry so i
highly recommend that you explore more
there's there's so much more in the css
world than i can cover in 45 minutes
initial letters the cool specification
that you can actually do some cool stuff
with the first letter of
text you can make it like span multiple
lines instead of doing height
you can use css transforms for more than
just animations you can do like skews
and rotates and three-dimensional things
object fit brings the background size
cover
and the idea of like placing a
background image to foreground images
it's super cool
uh css filters bring a whole bunch of
like photoshop filter kind of things
like grayscale and like really wacky
stuff you can use
uh into the browser clip path is a way
of actually like clipping out
a an image or even a div with text
inside of it to actually have
a shape on your site as well i want
closed four questions and say
there's no shame in using templates
there's no shame in using bootstrap or
bulma or foundation
but understand what these things do and
how to break out of it when you need to
and how to do
little things on your own because css is
super powerful
if you learn a few things you can make
super interesting designs and you can
start today
you don't have to wait for 100 adoption
because that would actually be kind of
terrible to wait for because you never
get there because plenty of people are
still using ie10
but you want to fall back with an idea
of support first
right so start from a point of support
and go forward and we can do that
with css feature queries to allow for us
to
support browsers that support these
things without resorting to javascript
so in our css this is from our
asymmetric grid example from before
we could actually have a flex layout as
our basic layout and this
flex layout would give us two boxes side
by side and then two boxes side by side
with a little bit of margin
and then inside what we call a feature
query which looks a lot like a media
query but with the word supports
uh it's a supports display grid so this
says for any browser that supports grid
do this other code and the important
thing to note here is
we unset two properties right so we
unset
width 100 or we unset our width
calculation from our promo
to make it 100 because grid actually
changes the context of its children
to have percentages be percentage of the
area as opposed to percentage of the
parent
and then margin bottom we get rid of
that so we can use gap and set and then
it's just the rest of our grid code
inside of that
so lookup feature queries work with
feature queries it's a way of having
resilient
web design as jen simmons calls it or as
i like to say support for
css uh so a little bit of homework for
you before i take questions
go learn one of these new layout things
today and one of these new style things
today and then
tell me on twitter what you picked
whatever you want picked right send me a
message at b-rob
brob let me know what you picked uh to
learn
i'm also always willing to help that's
not me that's my child from like two
years ago but still an adorable picture
i'd love to help you learn these things
go to brianalrobinson.com
there's a free advice button you can
click you can get a little bit of my
time that way
hit me up on twitter at bro i also
stream code i used to be
daily but with cobin 19 it's a little
bit less than that at twitch tv
slash brianl robinson and now i'll take
questions if we have questions